[Music]  who are these new guys  and why are they here  [Music]  what is their place  in a world without a Superman  the Man of Steel is dead we saw the body  it's time for human beings to stop  relying on leagues and Titans and start  saving ourselves I can give each of you  the power to be your own hero  Clark's body disappears and suddenly  these new supermen show up out of the  blue who the hell are you I'm Superman  there is only one Superman  [Music]  you look like Superman but Superman died  in my arms for my people death doesn't  have to be the end terrible things are  coming Lois  I could feel it we gotta be our own  heroes we show us how to make some noise  The Daily Planet said Superman is dead  it painted a target on the earth how do  we even begin to fight that  [Music]  [Music]